bienvenidos a reportero es el magazine
de los grandes reportajes de la
redacción de france 24 comenzamos
el 13 de enero de 2022 se llevó a cabo
el primer juicio contra un alto
funcionario del régimen sino un ex
oficial de los servicios de inteligencia
fue condenado a cadena perpetua en
alemania por crímenes de lesa humanidad
aguarrás la antiguo jefe de
interrogatorios en un centro de
detención en damasco fue declarado
culpable de 4.000 casos de tortura y 27
muertes de detenidos un año después de
la primera condena de un subordinado
suyo por parte del mismo tribunal alemán
los vetos ruso y chino bloquean desde
hace años el pronunciamiento de la corte
penal internacional
así que las autoridades judiciales
alemanas decidieron instruir el caso en
virtud de la jurisdicción universal el
camino hacia la justicia ha sido largo
pero para las víctimas y sus abogados
este juicio es tan sólo el comienzo
aun quedan muchos antiguos torturadores
sirios instalados en europa desde 2003 y
a continuación veremos el reportaje
realizado por marín pradel
de antes
[Música]
coblenza situada donde influye en el
ring y el mosela 4000 kilómetros separan
esta ciudad alemana de tamaño medio de
damasco la capital siria sin embargo
aquí es donde se está llevando a cabo el
primer juicio por crímenes de lesa
humanidad contra un oficial de alto
rango sirio
esta mañana el pequeño palacio de
justicia de la ciudad apenas puede
acoger a las víctimas familias de
desaparecidos y sus abogados para
escuchar el veredicto
casi dos años después de la apertura del
juicio
no creo que pueda sentarme adentro las
personas han estado haciendo fila desde
hace 6 horas
six award
todos han venido a escuchar de la boca
del juez alemán las siguientes palabras
culpable y crímenes de lesa humanidad el
hombre en el banquillo de los acusados
es anuar razlan jefe de interrogatorios
de la rama 251 un centro de detención y
tortura de los servicios de inteligencia
en damasco
y
todo este sistema esta organización esta
máquina que detiene
tortura y mata a los sirios
ese es mi enemigo esa estructura
el lance parte de esa estructura no es
mi enemigo personal
y sin embargo este abogado siguió que
sobrevivió a las cárceles del régimen
tiene una historia muy personal con el
acusado
anuar al bunni fue secuestrado en 2006
en medio de una calle de damasco por un
hombre llamado anuar raslan
[Música]
cuando salió de la cárcel anuar al bunni
huyó del país y se refugió en berlín en
2014 con su mujer y sus hijos en este
centro para refugiados
cuando llegue vivía ahí en ese
apartamento en el segundo piso
tres años después del inicio del
levantamiento popular contra el régimen
de al asad cientos de miles de sirios
empezaron a huir hacia europa y alemania
entonces pase por esta puerta para salir
y esa fue la primera vez que lo vi en
esa pequeña calle
delante de él su secuestrador anual
raslan
por su mirada supe de inmediato que me
había reconocido
él aún no lo sabía pero en ese momento
otros defensores de derechos humanos ya
se encontraban siguiendo a raslan
[Aplausos]
cuando anuar al bunni fue convocado por
la policía alemana para declarar reforzó
las sospechas de los investigadores
y me llamaron para tomar mi declaración
y me preguntaron si había otras víctimas
que quisieran hacer parte del proceso
así que por supuesto les ayude
porque yo ya conocía a la mayoría de las
víctimas y de los testigos los defendí
en esa época cuando habían sido
arrestados y detenidos en el centro
en su pequeña oficina berlinesa anuar al
bunni recopila los testimonios contra
razlan pero también contra decenas de
otros criminales de guerra sirios
presentes en suelo europeo no pasa un
solo día sin que reciba una alerta
en messenger
alguien localizó uno de los criminales
que lo arrestó y lo torturó usted en
antorchas
lo localizaron en suecia reconocieron su
rostro y su nombre y me están
contactando porque quieren saber qué
hacer
acaba de recibir ese mensaje sí sí justo
ahora esto pasa con frecuencia
si todos los días todos los días recibo
mensajes como este de todas partes de
europa
y de todas partes
[Música]
en 2019 and marras land fue arrestado
junto con uno de sus subordinados de la
rama 251 fue necesario preparar el
futuro juicio que no se llevaría a cabo
en la corte penal internacional a causa
de los vetos ruso y chino sino en un
tribunal alemán con abogados alemanes
como patrick crocker
[Música]
él representa a nueve de los
veinticuatro sobrevivientes que componen
las partes civiles
en derecho penal internacional si los
crímenes son tan graves que se
convierten en crímenes internacionales
como los crímenes de lesa humanidad los
crímenes de guerra o los crímenes de
genocidios existe un principio llamado
la jurisdicción universal que hace que
estos crímenes puedan ser juzgados en
cualquier parte del mundo por supuesto
eso depende de cada estado de la manera
en la que cada país incorpore ese
principio de jurisdicción universal
dentro de su propio ordenamiento
jurídico y alemania en este caso lo hizo
de manera muy amplia y es por esa razón
que el fiscal general alemán pudo
empezar a investigar los archivos sirios
desde 2011
patrick a crocker ha trabajado en este
archivo desde hace 4 años convencer a
sus clientes de dar testimonio delante
del tribunal no fue fácil porque aunque
son refugiados en suelo europeo el miedo
es permanente los servicios secretos
sirios en mujabarat tocan a sus puertas
a la casa de su padre de su sobrino de
su hermano de su madre y dicen
nos enteramos de que su hijo o su
sobrina quiere dar testimonio en el
tribunal de coblenza
y no estamos muy contentos realmente
deberían decirle algo y el mensaje queda
muy claro para todo el mundo el próximo
paso es que esa persona podría ser
encarcelada y torturada
[Música]
robaina canán también es una de las
sobrevivientes hoy en día es refugiada
política en francia y estudiante
universitaria
[Música]
pero al comienzo de la revolución en
síria la joven periodista de radio
soñaba con la democracia y la libertad
en 2012 fue detenida en damasco y
conducida al centro
cuando llegue a la rama 251 empezó la
tortura
trataban a los detenidos como cosas no
como personas para ellos no hay ningún
límite en el dolor que pueden infringir
y cuando me llevaron el interrogatorio
me golpearon
y vi a hombres jóvenes colgados del
techo por las muñecas
unos al lado de otros desnudos siendo
golpeados todos los días había alguien
nuevo
[Música]
después del arresto de ras land robaina
viajó a berlín para ser interrogada por
la policía diez horas de preguntas
íntimas y difíciles
era agotador psicológica y físicamente y
me recordó a algo que estaba tratando de
olvidar
luego en noviembre de 2020 testificó en
el tribunal de coblenza
delante de ella en el banquillo de los
acusados anual razlan
lo miraba todo el tiempo quería que me
mirarán quería decirles matar mira ahora
tú y yo estamos los dos delante de un
tribunal en cuatro horas de audiencia
nunca me miró nunca hola alfanje no
el principal reto del juicio era probar
el carácter sistemático e
institucionalizado de las estructuras lo
cual convertiría estos crímenes en
crímenes de lesa humanidad
en este sótano de una gran ciudad de
europa del oeste hay 900 kilos de papel
un millón de documentos las actas
administrativas de la máquina de muerte
siria con firmas del puño de victimarios
burócratas entre las cuales se encuentra
la de bashar al-assad en persona
nerma jelacic co dirige las hijas
la comisión de la justicia internacional
y la responsabilidad los crímenes es uno
de los tres rostros conocidos de la
organización compuesta por una centena
de miembros todos anónimos
nuestros equipos están en la mira tanto
en siria como en el extranjero
así que tenemos reglas de seguridad muy
estrictas
y las veces en la que hemos tenido
brechas en el protocolo de seguridad
hemos tenido que cambiarlo todo nos
hemos visto forzados a mudarnos
a cambiar varias veces de país
las hijas ex filtro la mayoría de estos
documentos de los edificios oficiales
sirios cuando una gran parte del
territorio estaba en manos de la
oposición hasta 2016 y en medio de la
montaña de papeles encontraron registros
de interrogatorios firmados por anuar
raslan
los documentos de las hijas son muy
importantes no solo porque demuestran la
implicación directa del acusado
sino también porque muestran su papel y
el de sus equipos en este amplio y vasto
archipiélago de violencia y tortura
desplegado por el régimen
otro elemento clave del juicio las fotos
del expediente césar nombre de un
oficial de la inteligencia militar y ex
filtro de siria las fotos de los cuerpos
de más de seis mil sirios que murieron
por hambre y por tortura en los centros
de detención del régimen
sabéis
esta es una muerte debida a un golpe
brutal en la nuca
esta es por compresión de los tejidos
del cuello
este experto forense estuvo tres años
analizando 27.000 imágenes del archivo
las detalló clínicamente delante del
tribunal como estudiamos esas fotos
durante un largo periodo de tiempo al
final llegamos a un punto en el que
pensábamos que ya habíamos trabajado
sobre una foto yo pensaba me equivoqué
retomé un archivo que ya estudiamos y
estoy analizando una foto sobre la que
ya había trabajado hasta que en un
momento se volvió evidente que en
realidad los casos no solo eran muy
similares dentro de una prisión sino
también entre los distintos centros de
detención y así fue como pudimos aportar
las pruebas de que existe una especie de
sistema que rige la manera en la que las
personas son tratadas y heridas en estas
prisiones
anual razlan admitió que la tortura era
sistemática pero negó toda implicación
personal
[Música]
en parís uruguay de canal trata de
olvidar
[Música]
pero decidió ir a sentarse una última
vez delante de su victimario
[Música]
me parece difícil alegrarme porque
pienso en mis amigos que todavía están
detenidos estarían contentos con lo que
estamos haciendo aquí no lo sé
[Música]
jueves 13 de enero después de 100 días
de audiencia el juicio llega a su fin
trate de dormir pero no lo lograba todo
el tiempo estaba pensando en lo que iría
a pasar hoy
dos horas después se anuncia el
veredicto cadena perpetua para no
arrastrar
es algo increíble
el tribunal denuncia a ese estado de
seguridad que comete crimen y
suscripción gran día para siria después
de esto no veo como un país que respete
los derechos humanos
pueda seguir hablando con el régimen de
asad lo siento
más de siete años después de haberse
cruzado con su secuestrador en la calle
anuar al bunni puede cerrar este
capítulo y concentrarse en nosotros
se abrirán muchos juicios y en austria
en alemania en suecia en los países
bajos en bélgica en suiza seguiremos con
nuestra misión para mí no es un trabajo
es mi misión es mi vida así que mientras
siga en vida esta lucha continuará
forzada así continuó my life así es
continua
cree que algún día bashar al-assad será
juzgado no estoy seguro para mí no se
trata de una esperanza es mi objetivo ex
gol
una semana después en frankfurt se abrió
el juicio contra un médico sirio acusado
de haber torturado a manifestantes en
los hospitales por cuenta del régimen él
también pensaba haber encontrado una
nueva vida en europa
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde para sintonizar esta y las
ediciones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]